[Music]
some other big stars discovered today
rich with nominations for Screen Actors
Guild Award and can I just say niecy
Nash and Olivia Munn clearly get the
award for best announcing duo Benedict
Cumberbatch Sherlock The Lying detective
that's a dramatic I'm gonna step it up
on my turn next time okay let's get
through this I'm gonna I'm gonna give it
to you guys okay
taking what is usually a laundry list of
nominees read from a teleprompter and
making it all their own Puzo aduba
orange the new black first of all
Vanessa and Olivia show I need it in my
life I need in my life nisi and Olivia
met for the first time just this morning
they told me it was a spontaneous
decision to go totally off script
blackish
then that's all the press would be about
if that I'd be pointed to you go
if fresh-off-the-boat comes up don't
point at me okay somebody's just
probably writing a buddy comedy for us
right now the duo are setting the tone
for what is going to be a celebration of
women in Hollywood when the SAG Awards
broadcast live January 21st on TNT and
TBS ET has learned that all 13 acting
awards will be presented by women the
nominees in the various categories
include Nicole Kidman Reese Witherspoon
Laura Dern Margot Robbie Allison Janney
and mary j blige Kristen Bell has also
been tapped as the first-ever SAG Awards
host she told us the pressure is on to
get it right and so nervous the stakes
are high I guess being the first person
ever cuz you you have other people to
look to if you do a different award show
it is also the first time Kevin Spacey
has not been nominated as an actor in
house of cards he was fired last month
for allegations of sexual misconduct
Spacey's on-screen wife Robin Wright was
recognized and having Robin Wright get
nominate meaning she should have gotten
nominated I'm super excited for her to
hold down that show on her own
you
[Music]